right if you are the average American
that works hard plays by the rules pays
their taxes raises their kids and and
serves the country every day providing
goods and services good Americans need
to step back tonight
this isn't about Republican Democrat
conservative or liberal at all with no
due process zero corroborating evidence
the left in America is now smearing an
individual and they've been doing it now
for 15 consecutive days calling him evil
accusing him of being a serial rapist a
sexual predator a violent drunk a liar a
perjurer much more classic character
assassination of a man who has served
his country and it's been in the
spotlight now for almost 40 years
without a single whiff of misconduct
until 15 days ago as we Americans now we
better get this as a country right
because a collective rush to judgment
getting rid of all presumption of
innocence and due process it is a clear
and present danger to all of you to
every American and tonight at a huge
rally and Johnson City Tennessee
President Trump stood up for his Supreme
Court nominee and the pillar of what is
America's justice system the presumption
of innocence let's watch the president
Democrats are willing to do anything and
to hurt anyone to get their way like
they're doing with Judge Cavanaugh
[Music]
[Applause]
they've been trying to destroy him since
the very first second he was announced
because they know the judge Cavan will
follow the Constitution as written that
he's a good man
great student great intellect never had
a problem all of a sudden no let's go
back to high school they maybe should go
before high school and then they want to
take a lot longer with the FBI no the
FBI they should take by the way
if we took ten years and one more time
so here we are day 15 the Democrats are
attempt to stop judge Cavanaugh at all
costs and by way at a wild press
conference earlier today the president
let loose had this to say about the
important process that the media and
Democrats they're trying to now upend
this is dangerous but he took it on take
a look I want the FBI this is now their
seventh investigation so it's not like
they you know just starting I want them
to do a very comprehensive investigation
whatever that means
according to the Senators and the
Republicans and the Republican majority
I want them to do that and the reason
I'd like it to go quickly very simple
it's so simple because it's unfair to
him at this point what his wife is going
through what his beautiful children are
going through is not describable it's
not describable it's not fair now of
course Cavanaugh's vote was once again
delayed last week because the left
successfully coerced one notoriously
flaky Republican senator to go along
with their demands a new background
check into the allegations made by
professor Christine Ford limited in
scope only a week this weekend Senator
Jeff Flake sat down with one of his
Democratic colleagues on 60 minutes to
Pat himself on the back for his heroic
stance he was out running for president
in Massachusetts earlier today but he
did admit in the interview if he was
seeking re-election he never would have
done this ever and came to the
Democratic demands he's now their hero
take a look if you've announced that
you're not running for reelection and I
won
could you have done this if you were
running no your life no not a chance
not a chance no no because politics has
become too sharp too partisan there's no
value to reaching across the aisle
there's no currency for that anymore
there's no incentive I just lie like I
always did
now tonight the FBI's background check
in to Professor Ford these are all
important facts we've got to remember it
is well underway but Rachel Mitchell
remember the independent prosecutor
hired by the Senate Judiciary Committee
to question both professor Ford and
judge Cavanaugh well she has already
released her report to the Senate
Judiciary Committee in these findings
they're devastating this is what she
says he said she said case is incredibly
difficult to prove but this case is even
weaker than that dr. Ford identified are
the witnesses to the event and those
witnesses either refuted or allegations
or failed to corroborate them now for
the reasons discussed below I do not
think any reasonable prosecutor would
bring this case based on the evidence
before the committee and the prosecutor
went on to list multiple issues where
Professor Ford's accusations including
no consistent account of when the
alleged assault actually happened a
failure to previously identified Judge
Cavanaugh as the assailant as the
assailant inconsistent descriptions of
the alleged assault a failure to
remember key details including who
invited forward to the party how she got
to the party where the party even took
place and how she got home from the
party she does however remember
unrelated details like the consumption
of exactly one beer and that she took no
medication that day another issue listed
by prosecutors surrounds the fact that
Ford's allegations have been
corroborated by nobody including a
lifelong friend and dr. Ford also
struggled to recall recent events
related to her accusation including the
date of her polygraph test now there are
also inconsistencies with ford's
psychological trauma claims including
her alleged fear of flying despite the
fact that she flies frequently in many
of her hobbies involve flying all over
the world and Rachael mish Mitchell also
reported quote the activities of
congressional Democrats in dr. Ford's
attorneys
likely affected dr. Ford's account it is
important to remember that senator
Feinstein and this is where we get into
facts matter corroboration matters
she mentioned these four people none of
them corroborated a story including an
alleged eyewitness to the incident and
Dianne Feinstein played politics with
professor Ford's very serious claims
from the very beginning she knew about
this in July and last week Senate
Democrats demanding an FBI investigation
but Feinstein and her colleagues have
known about this as I said since July
where's their calls for an investigation
into keith Ellison or for that matter
Juanita Broderick and Bill Clinton
why didn't senator Feinstein ask
Cavanaugh about these allegations when
they met personally why at the very same
time she's advising professor Ford on
what attorney to hire instead of
contacting her with a qualified
experienced nonpartisan lawyer
well Feinstein suggested what turns out
to be a partisan left-winger big-time
democratic donor named Deborah Katz once
proclaimed on national TV she would
resist President Trump she dismissed
Paula Jones well it was only 10 to 12
minutes excuse me he exposed himself
Bill Clinton at the time that was the
allegation and then she defended creepy
Senator Al Franken and according to a
report from the Washington free beacon
tonight one of Katz's close friends is
now searching for anyone willing to come
forward against Cavanaugh they're
sending out emails to people literally
soliciting people as late as last week
now Feinstein cared about getting to the
truth why suggest a democratic hack
that's inconsistent on what is a serious
issue today and meanwhile even though
Professor Ford requested her name remain
private it was leaked because
congressional Democrats were the only
officials with access to her story and
Senate Republicans are now vowing
rightly so to investigate Dianne
Feinstein and the Democrats handling of
this case of course senator Feinstein is
denying any responsibility for the leaks
but earlier today President Trump called
out the senator for her shameless
political tactics and they were
shameless take a look Diane Feinstein
knew about this
months earlier if she wanted a really
thorough investigation we had all the
time in the world she didn't have to
wait till after the hearing was closed
essentially she should have said listen
I have a problem I have this report I'd
like the FBI to look at it while we're
doing the earrings we had two months for
the Democrats to be talking about we
want more time for the FBI if you wanted
more time for the FBI
why didn't Dianne Feinstein bring this
up
why didn't she America deserves an
answer to that question and why didn't
she tell her Republican colleagues and
then say all we need time we can't rush
this we had plenty of time and Democrats
are continuing their political stall
tactics last week it was a narrow
investigation limited to only a week now
despite President Trump ordering the FBI
to investigate any and all legitimate
claims it's still not enough for the
left they want FBI investigations into
every single claim made against
Cavanaugh no matter how unsubstantiated
and some are even calling for
investigations into whether or not
Cavanaugh lied about how much he drank
in high school he said sometimes he
drank a lot like a lot of kids in high
school in college now that's called
moving the goalposts that's called
changing the game in the middle of it
and as we've been saying for months they
want to stall the nomination they want
the midterm elections these facts all
matter because 36 days you we the people
do you want to put these people in power
they want to impeach the president
endless investigation they want their
crumbs back they won't open borders and
they want to keep Obamacare of course if
the FBI does extend the investigation
into the second accuser then the third
accuser well we already know about the
second accuser and we find again
unsubstantiated claims from a woman
who's claiming that Kavanagh may have
exposed her himself to hurt a drunken
college party when he was a college
freshman she doesn't really remember in
fact she said she wasn't totally sure of
Kavanagh was the perpetrator she called
around according to the New York Times
to see if they remember the incident
whether it was him they did not and she
even acknowledges that she has
significant memory gaps from that
evening New York Times refused to report
this
because of the lack of evidence and of
course is the third accuser her name is
Julie sweat Nick in this case the FBI is
likely to find a lot of inconsistencies
from her wild allegations remember she's
claiming Kavanaugh was involved in the
serial drugging and gang rape scheme in
the 80s that happened almost every
weekend and she went to ten of these
parties and today's sweat neck
represented by the all fame-seeking
attorney michael avenatti the new face
of the Democratic Party sat down with
NBC News and what turned out for NBC by
the end of the day to be a disaster take
a look in that statement sweat Nick said
she became aware of efforts by Kavanaugh
and his friend mark judge to spike punch
at parties in our interview she said she
saw them near the punch but did not
specifically say she saw either man
spiked it did you see Brett Kavanaugh
you know spiking the punch putting green
eyes I saw I saw him giving Red Solo
cups to quite a few girls during that
time frame I saw him around the punch I
won't say bowls or the punch containers
I don't know what he did but I saw him
buy them are their friends who remember
these parties - and remember oh I think
everybody in the county remembers of his
parties because we have we haven't heard
from those friends so I'm asking you
know are there people yes today yes
parties yes there are people that know
about those parties this morning sweat
Nick provided four names of friends she
says went to the parties with her one of
them said he does not recall a Julie
sweat Nick another of the friends she
named his deceased we've reached out to
the other two and haven't heard back
still zero corroboration the same NBC
news that sat on that interview with
Juanita Broderick when she was making
rape allegations about Bill Clinton they
refused to air her for over a month all
because they said it couldn't be
corroborated they needed time to vet it
NBC should this is a disgrace this is
not news this is them letting an
individual make uncorroborated claims
and then just airing it here they are
running totally unverified
uncorroborated claims against judge
Kavanaugh and
multiple inconsistencies yet again are
there any new standards over there
should we at all be surprised this is
now in a mitigated disaster for NBC News
by the way Tom Brokaw if you're watching
or somebody calls you in three minutes
would you air this you need to speak out
publicly you spent your whole life
trying to build that brand all three of
these stories do have one thing in
common
zero corroborating evidence outright
denials of so-called witnesses and many
inconsistencies after all this is how
your mainstream media is now treating
the ongoing Supreme Court battle this
weekend a cartoonist drew this vile
depiction of Judge Cavanaugh's young
daughter praying for her quote angry
lying alcoholic father for sexually
assaulting dr. Ford never made it into a
newspaper the cartoonist published it
online on his own didn't return our
request for comment shocking and then
there's the media darling James Comey
and of course is calling for an a
limited time frame for FBI
investigations and bashing anybody get
this who won't sit down with FBI
investigators writing quote most people
will speak to the FBI refusal to do so
is its own kind of statement and I'm
thinking really ask general Flynn and
Schwartz Papadopoulos about speaking to
the FBI that literally worked out
perfect for them in the case of even
general Flynn they didn't think he lied
he was charged with lying now when you
see all these anti Calvin op-eds and
people like Jim Comey asking for more
information when you see the media
rushing to judgment when you see
Democrats demanding more and more
investigations you've got to remember
this one clear point and this is what
matters tonight this is all about
politics it's now about power it's not
about the truth Democrats have been
against Cavanaugh publicly from the day
he was announced no matter what this
investigation finds them never going to
vote for him anyway they never were it's
likely every single important event in
modern history this is a matter that we
better get right if you
I have evidence and you're gonna rush to
judgment and you're gonna have zero
presumption of innocence by the way this
is not the first time Ferguson Missouri
Richard Jewell Baltimore Maryland
Cambridge police Duke Lacrosse UVA rape
allegations now judge Kavanagh Clarence
Thomas we have a party of smear slander
lies and no due process none
this shouldn't be political and all
their left-wing friends in the
mainstream media the deep state are
backing them up all along the way there
is no life they're not willing to
destroy for power no reputation they
won't defile no process they won't
corrupt at this point no issue they
won't politicize and that means there's
no shame their actions are literally as
we speak reprehensible and we've got a
lot to get to tonight